Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vous fais une vidéo en dehors du planning habituel
parce que j'ai besoin de vous dire une bonne fois pour toute où est-ce que je vais être et où est-ce qu'on peut se rencontrer.
Vous me posez souvent la question dans les commentaires des vidéos ou sur les réseaux sociaux donc là au lieu de répondre en dispatché.
Ça devient compliqué, je vous réponds à tous en même temps. Pour les dédicaces du livre "Votre Cerveau Est Extraordinaire",
j'ai déjà fait La Rochelle et Caen au mois de juin.
Là je vais être le 30 septembre, c'est à dire samedi prochain à la Fnac de Mulhouse à partir de 15H.
Le 21 octobre ce sera à Lyon à la librairie Decitre et ce sera à partir de 16H.
Je crois qu'il y a deux librairies comme ça renseignez vous pour savoir laquelle est la bonne.
Le 28 octobre ce sera la fnac de Troyes et je n'ai pas encore l'heure mais je pense que la Fnac vous le dire avant que je le sache.
Le 29 octobre je serai à Paris au Grand Point Virgule en spectacle
et donc à la sortie je dédicacerai les livres pour ceux qui sont au venu au spectacle évidemment.
Par contre je dis pas ça pour faire de la pub puisque c'est déjà complet
Le 4 novembre, ce sera à Bègles au Cultura à partir de 14H30
et le 25 novembre ce sera toute la journée au festival du livre de Colmar le matin, le soir, l'après midi, tout le temps !
Evidemment il y aura d'autres villes qui vont se rajouter je sais qu'il ya Brest et Bordeaux
qui sont en cours de discussion, ça dépend quand est ce que les librairies me demande ça dépend de quand est-ce que moi aussi je suis disponible.
Mais je vous tiendrai au courant de tout ça sur le site internet: www.fabienolicard.fr et sur les réseaux sociaux
Ça c'était pour les dédicaces ensuite en terme de spectacle,
je sais que vous êtes nombreux également à me demander quand est-ce que je passe dans votre ville
sachant que de janvier à juin j'ai déjà fait 100 villes et souvent celles qu'on me redemande donc je vais pas refaire de tournée tout
de suite, en réalité. Là les seules choses qui vont se passer il va y avoir les Mandrake d'Or au Casino de Paris où je suis
dessus c'est pas mon spectacle entier je suis juste un passage. Idem pour la suisse où je serai au gala de Montreux sur le gala de Pierre Croce où je ferai un numéro est par contre vous savez
peut-être maintenant je serai donc à l'Olympia le 22 septembre 2018 l'année prochaine.
Ça c'est vraiment le truc le plus ouf qu'il puisse arriver dans la vie d'un artiste et pour l'Olympia la règle du jeu est différente,
c'est à dire d'habitude c'est moi qui fais des centaines de villes pour allez vous voir là c'est à vous de vous organiser. Il y a un an ! Ça va !
Pour venir à Paris assister à la date. C'est du placement numéroté donc plus vous prenez vos places tôt
plus vous pouvez avoir le siège que vous voulez et surtout moi plus je peux m'organiser
à préparer des trucs en fonction du remplissage. Tant qu'on est à faire des annonces et pas une vidéo comme d'habitude je vais être aussi
sur d'autres événements genre des salons des fois, des conférences je sais que je fais
une conférence pour le neuro planète qui se passe à Nice. Je ne peux pas vous annoncer tout ça tout le temps sur la chaîne sinon
je vais vous saouler un moment donné donc n'hésitez pas à faire un clic pour me rajouter sur instagram ou sur twitter ou même sur
facebook et snapchat j'annonce toujours ce genre de choses quand ça va arriver et puis et pas que ça je poste pas que des trucs
intelligents sur les réseaux sociaux loin de là d'ailleurs !
Donc ça déjà c'est un programme bien chargé donc il y a moins de spectacles en tournée en ce moment pour la raison vous ai
donnée parce que j'ai fait 100 déjà
représentations entre janvier et juin
et aussi parce qu'actuellement vous commencez à me connaître je suis encore sur d'autres projets, d'autres trucs que je vais vous annoncer bientôt.
Concrètement il y a trois choses que je suis en train d'essayer de créer pour vous surprendre
pour me faire kiffer pour vous faire kiffer, à voir ce qui aboutira ou pas mais ça ça me prend du temps. Bref la tournée de
dédicaces en tout cas je fais vraiment ça pour venir à votre rencontre
y a rien à payer c'est gratuit même si vous n'avez pas de livre vous pouvez venir il y a aucun problème
c'est un peu comme un meet up améliorer et je vous met un lien dans la description qui reprend le parcours des dates de dédicaces
encore une fois il va évoluer avec le temps avec d'autre dates qui vont se rajouter et je vous mets également un petit lien pour
l'Olympia, alors oui c'était une vidéo vraiment hors planning parce que hors format et la vidéo habituels sort demain sur la chaîne
il n'y a pas de souci on ne dislike pas on ne rage pas d'avoir une vidéo comme ça je vous rappelle que moi je
vois toutes vos questions tout le temps passer et que je viens d'y répondre
Bien sûr évidemment merci encore d'être toujours là aussi présent je vous mets ici le petit cercle
d'abonnements parce que figurez vous qu'une personne sur deux qui regardent les vidéos n'est pas abonné à la chaîne
et ça il faut que ça change abonnez vous. vous pouvez même depuis le smartphone à bientôt !
Ciao !